Lyndsey's with us Lindsay's in Phoenix
Arizona how are you Lindsay welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show someday how are you
doing better than I deserve what's up
I'm 22 a recent college grad and I am
debt free and I have been talking to my
parents and they recommend that I get a
credit card to start putting my
groceries on it and paying it off right
away to build credit and say something
happens to my 13 year old car you need
to get a new car what do you recommend
well I recommend if you want to get into
debt and stay in debt and live a life of
debt for the rest of your life that you
follow their advice hey if you don't
know if you don't want to get into debt
then there's not any point in building
your credit is there that's what I
thought but they're concerned that I
won't be able to get like a home or
anything like that if I don't have
credit mm-hmm that's because they don't
know what they're talking about you can
qualify for a mortgage to buy a home if
you have zero credit you just have to
have paid your landlord on time you have
to have a steady job you have a
reasonable down payment those kinds of
things and when you get ready to replace
your 13 year old car you should have
saved money and do that with cash
otherwise you're going to be like
everybody else and live paycheck to
paycheck and car payment to car payment
and credit card payment to credit card
payment and we're going to go into debt
why so we have the opportunity to run up
our credit so we have the so then we can
more easily get more debt why because
then we have the opportunity to build up
our credit so that we can more easily go
into debt and we live our lives trying
to worship at the altar of the great
FICO score instead of trying to build
wealth I think it's a broken philosophy
Lindsey okay all right you kind of knew
that when you called me right yeah I did
I just wanted to make sure that I wasn't
being you know disrespectful 22 year old
got it well you know it's how you
respond if you respond like I just
responded it might be disrespectful but
I don't really care if they think I
disrespected them because I'm not really
disrespecting them I'm disrespecting the
culture and the cultural acceptance of
the stupid suggestion that they made
they made a suggestion thinking they
were doing something good for their
daughter and the reason is is they
Malte lie and I haven't had a credit
card or borrowed a dime in 25 years
Wow isn't that weird and you're sitting
there debt-free why are you debt-free
if being and dad is so sexy why aren't
you in debt when I went to college that
was supported by a bunch of churches and
actually made it possible for the
students why do you think they did that
because debt is not a good idea and so
you know that it's there they're moving
you that way because here's the deal if
you just spend your most powerful wealth
building tool for your future is your
income and every time you sign up for
payments you have less of your income
because you have to come you've
committed more of it to the bank
proverbs 22:7 says the borrower is slave
to the lender and the first level of
slavery there is mathematical because
when you commit all of what you're
working for to somebody else you don't
have any money and that's what most
people do and so I'm going to you know
really try to talk you into not living a
life of payment - payment worshipping at
the altar of the great FICO as if he is
your provider the FICO score because
he's not your provider thanks for the
call